i used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time
[Music]
but things changed
[Applause]
called father now we flash back to your
younger self in this
yeah the actor that played the younger
dom toretto did a phenomenal job but
then i thought about the young vin
diesel
you at that age yeah what was that like
i started bouncing at 17 18.
i had been acting for 10 years
doing off off off off off broadway
if i remember going if i'm not a star by
the time i'm 15 i'm just going to stop
then if i'm gonna start before i have to
go to college all this stuff
and then if i'm not observing and then
of course
i didn't get paid as an actor until i
was 30 years old
wow i'm saving program wow i
was happy
i grew up in the coolest building
in the coolest neighborhood in the
coolest city
in the cooling country in the world and
literally i grew up in an artist housing
i just was filled with optimism in spite
of the evidence
and i just so
much it was the 80s and i just so
much loved being
me i felt like even though i
i was struggling and even
i couldn't get i had so much confidence
well even though you say that
you said you know about being you i know
people think you and this character are
synonymous and you are at this point
after 20 years
but i know there's a dom shrine that you
go into to get into character
that's so true and that you have a wall
that justin lynn talked about with all
the characters and string
what is that who who do you leave behind
to be dumb
like what happens in that shrine we'll
never see it what what is in
unfortunately well it's part of the
process but
everyone i leave behind the son
the brother the father
justin lin was with me working with me
that
during the day on the night that my son
was born
and jumped cut to my son being eight
years old
and him casting him to play young dom
wow
and he did a great job not my idea
really and not not only not my idea
i don't know if i would have how
i guess um happy hours about the idea
and i'll tell you why
my when i go home i'm dad
but for my son to be on set
windham is going through a very deep
moment
filled with reflection he's not on set
with his father
he's on set with someone else albeit dom
toretto
that he knows but he's not on set with
his father
when i got home i'll never forget this
twinkle that he had in his eye uh-oh
when his
father had returned wow he had worked
all day and he's striving to do the best
to
to to make justin
proud and and to make justin happy
um but all along saw
almost me lost in character wow
um
and it's a surreal
thing to remember but i do remember it
and so when you say what do you leave
behind you leave it all behind
um
i feel like growing up in new york
were you know as kids we're always
trying to
kind of find our identity in spite of
the confidence i was searching for my
identity
and i think that characters at a young
age i remember
playing characters on a script
it was therapeutic in a way because the
parameters
of your identity we're clear
so i don't know how that relates but
when well
let me ask you moving forward because
i'm already looking forward i know you
and justin are looking forward to 10.
wrapping this up do you have the end
game in sight have you seen dom's last
shot
do you have it in your mind do you know
where it is
and then moving forward what if fans
aren't done
what if you're not done a man is it a
profound one
and what if the audience is not ready
what if you learn a lot of things in
life
and yeah
sometimes we're not ready
sometimes we're just not ready i don't
know how that answers it does that mean
it'll keep going
do you see how it could spin off uh well
i i think
i well i'm glad you asked that nikki
this is the end of this mythology
this is the end of this leg era
of the saga will the fast and furious
universe disappear
no it'll be more formidable than ever
but in but as a storyteller
that always lives with the pressure of
tomorrow
it can't be a book can't be never ending
a story must have a conclusion
just to pay homage just to in service of
the story
and it's sometimes they said we have
mixed feelings about coming upon the
conclusion
but that's where we are
okay so that means you are ending it
justin said there's always a chance
and i'll put in one request toreto and a
t-rex please
i knew it was coming oh
god i knew
five years from now uh-huh
five years from now
remember you said that okay
great to see you people are already
talking about the next movie we're
we still haven't had this movie land in
theaters yet right but i'm hearing
rumors of a jurassic park crossover
i don't know if you've heard about it
but would you be on board to like go
toe-to-toe
with like a velociraptor i've okay i i
heard those room but they
are someone made that up right like on
twitter
or something i don't know or did it did
it come from justin i mean i don't i
think somebody asked chris pratt about
it i think that's how it started and he
said he'd be down for it so i'm like now
i have to ask you guys if you'd be down
here it's really funny yeah of course
i'd be down for it
um i think it'd be really i mean i feel
like everyone hears these ideas and then
they go
no and then like maybe why not you know
what i mean
like why not crazier things have
happened
right because if you would have said in
the first one in this one you'd be going
to outer space
totally or even we started out as red
line and then all of a sudden
our title turned into fast and furious
and initially i was like no no that's
not a great title i don't understand
really yes oh i didn't know that worst
instincts ever
okay so you'd be you'd be cool with the
raptor you'd be cool with the jurassic
situation i'm gonna throw another
scenario at you
because i love bryce dallas howard i
think she's so amazing so like any
excuse to work with her yes oh she's
amazing
great director too yeah yeah she's good
but no justin
um well actually speaking of females
i'll go in that direction um
first all-female action scene in this
one as well
as the fact that you have a female
writer yes this time
how did that change the dynamic for you
and i heard you were just like get me in
there for that scene it really was
because i haven't really had action
since the fifth
and part that's partially because i was
tied up on a television show and i
wasn't able to like spend as much time
on the fast and furious sets which
killed me that absolutely killed me
um so i just said to justin like please
let me in there i would send him
pictures of me and
and videos of me training and because
i'm a really active person
and i love to train and so that was just
never really showcased
um so hopefully i get to do more of that
in the future so talking about the
future so what are you putting out there
for the next one because i'm sort of
picturing
like possibility of a spin-off or like
where do you see mia because i know
you're also thinking of tying things
up in the next few films unless the fans
demand more of course but where do you
would you like to see me ride off into
the sunset have you thought about the
end game for her like where would you
like to see her go i haven't thought
about the end game i would love more
action i would love to explore i loved
how
in nine we get to learn so much about
the the history of the torettos and why
things are the way they are and
um psychologically why the the
characters are where they're at and so
i would love to explore the relationship
with letty
i'd love to see i've never really had a
scene with ramsay either like i would
love to see the girls go off and do
their own thing for a little bit i think
that would be really fun
um and uh and yeah i just action action
action is what i want
okay so if you could have another cast
person be cast as another
long-lost relative who would you cast
i you know it would be really cool
penelope cruz or sandra bullock
i think would be really really cool we
know sandra bullock can drive fast
she can she can absolutely yeah i'm
seeing another crossover
totally totally those would be good okay
so i'm going to go off on another
tangent
the fact that you're going sci-fi in
this one i'm thinking
parallel universe if you guys were to
meet up with yourselves
in a parallel alternate timeline what
kind of
who who do you hope mia is and that you
get to go face face to face with because
you would get to also
obviously play her i would love mia to
inhabit
letty's persona a little bit more so
maybe like instead of becoming a mom
and being a good girl um
mia just like went completely the other
route
and went to prison and is just like
crazy
and like just doesn't listen to any
roles and it's just like
badass i love this idea right this needs
to happen
yes i agree yes and then you would have
scenes opposite her that would be
incredible amazing do i need to pitch
this i need to go back in justin's room
and do
please okay immediately um speaking of
family you had your children on set
i think your son plays a small yes yeah
the fact that this is 20 years later and
you know i just rewatched the first one
the the fashion has come back by the way
all that early 2000s
jeans with a cut off like because i know
i've been platforms like the whole thing
so good yeah i hope you kept some of
that wardrobe but
but just full circle like having going
from
that early 2000s now having your
children on set
like what it's amazing i mean it's
amazing because it's also the most
welcoming set
as a mom because vin's got his kids
there i've got my kids there
chris and so it's like they're all in a
camp kind of
it's it's really amazing and so i know
you guys got together in london and you
had your dinner
you have your dinner on screen and you
have your dinner off-screen was there an
initiation for john into the family
did you give him a bit of a hard time we
didn't
no i would i think it's hard enough for
someone walking into this set before
they
realize that we don't bite and like
we're cool and
i think the hard part is getting in and
then once you're in
like in within that's awesome no no no
just like
getting the role i think is what's hard
getting in the franchise
um so yeah i think that was
i think the toughest part about those
dinners is we all have to have a toast
so we all have to like get up and speak
and like i'm afraid of public speaking
in that sense
so i'm always like oh my god oh my god
what am i gonna say what am i gonna say
um but uh yeah john had a dinner for him
on his behalf and hopefully he felt very
welcome so what did you say
i was just like you were gonna have so
much fun enjoy this
and i was also a little bit starstruck
because it's john cena
and you know my son's also like a huge
john cena fan so
it was like wow you're gonna play my
brother like that's crazy
i think you might be on the wrong set
isn't that tasha's car behind you
you know what i'm saying you know
like if i see all of ludacris interviews
for this movie
and we're sitting on the same set i
didn't even physically get in the truck
matter of fact
i got in the truck in one scene and you
know what scene i'm talking about
okay but i have to say your
whole spectrum in this movie you get to
do it all
and listen doctor might live his life a
quarter mile at the top at a time but i
heard that when you read the script
you read it 20 pages at a time because
you were just like
mind blown i have to take a moment is
that
it's true it was a lot to it was a lot
in one sitting
um but you know
a lot of times when you read scripts
on like a transformers if a lot of stuff
is written for what they're going to be
doing and special effects and just the
stuff that's way
above my pay grade so it becomes like
you're reading it and you're just like
okay i don't really know how much of
this is for me
versus you know for them so i'm only
bringing up a romance
with you i'm not bringing it up with any
of the other cast members because it's
in your name roman
is moving forward as we're wrapping up
this franchise
is there going to be romance for roman
do
we think tej needs the romance he hasn't
had one
who should end up with the you know with
ramsey like i'm just saying
well here's the thing this would be my
first time
acknowledging this publicly but i think
tash has already gotten the girl
i think tash has already gotten ramsey
because i i think
what he did was he's gotten away from
all the jokes and the banter
that we used to have moment by moment
scene by
scene and he's kind of pivoted into
technology
and all of the you know typing in
computers and finding things in outer
space and god's
eyes and you know so he's kind of
he he i think he figured out her love
language
and and he's now he's
already got ramsey i think he got her so
roman definitely needs some romance
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna put
this
out there in the universe not only do i
think she's very beautiful
and has a lot of fire but i think she
has a personality that would make
all the sense in the world for roman's
first romance to be rihanna
okay oh rihanna so is this a dream
co-star
because i was going to ask you like we
don't see we get to see toretto's
backstory in this movie meet his family
when are we meeting your family
and who would that be and it's and
if we're going to see roman sort of like
as we're wrapping up this movie
i almost picture him on a beach
somewhere in the last shot with a lot of
snacks
and maybe rihanna what would be what's
your dream
for a roman of course i feel like i'm
listening to a roman pitch right now i
like it
uh but yeah i think i think you know her
name is bad girl riri for a reason you
know i think she makes all the sense in
the world for this franchise
i'm not trying to flirt i'm not trying
to be line and make a move
i'm i'm i'm specifically speaking
roman and saying you know who could i
see myself
having a few scenes with and being in
the car with me and
kind of taking certain journeys with me
and putting on leather and shooting and
doing all kind of hot girl action stuff
without even blinking it would be
rihanna this is your spin-off so they're
wrapping me but just one last question i
know you all have a cast dinner
together in london before you started
shooting this and that
vin makes everybody sort of stand up and
say something
what did you say what was your toast
um i don't want to say
it was a really long toast
it was a really long time coming before
we got
back to doing fast nine
and um boy was it good to be in that
room
and have that moment and listen to
all the people that have been thinking
and feeling and going through
the highs the amazing the breakthroughs
the challenges it was a moment and
it's something that i think we should
all keep near and dear to our
heart forever please tell me that's not
a pontiac fiero strapped to a rocket
engine
impressive i know no
no that's that's not impressive listen
i'm going back to the beginning and i'm
saying that the fashion is coming back
now
from the early 2000s you guys could
bring back all of that stuff
um first of all i just want to say
congratulations
on going to outer space thank you so
much before tom cruise richard branson
elon musk everybody tedge and roman went
to outer space
you inspired it according to justin your
existential crisis
inspired it so when you found out tell
me about that moment did you read the
script did somebody call you and tell
you guess what this is finally the film
we're going to the final frontier
i had to read the script two things
every time i get the new script i always
look
is ted's going to stay alive in this
damn franchise
and then number two what can we do that
we've never done before and as soon as i
read that
i was jumping for joy i loved it i was
like i couldn't i wouldn't have never
thought of that
ever really well it almost seemed like
because
you know people have teased it you know
people talked about it for so many films
now like when was it gonna happen
the fact that it was the two of you and
they chose to make it
so funny like laugh out loud everybody
was screaming
in the theater watching it just
give me a sense of what it felt like to
film it like the wardrobe everything was
so perfect
and how much riffing went on and how
much is on the cutting room floor like
could we have a director's cut of just
the two of you
like riffing that is such a great
question because they cut
a lot of it out of us being suspended in
air and
defying gravity because of you know the
space
trying to emulate space and one it was
very
uncomfortable because how we had to make
it happen and
and being on harnesses and things of
that nature and in these spacesuits
that were hot as hell was uncomfortable
but on the other hand it was absolutely
phenomenal because we knew we were
you know breaking new ground and doing
something that was going to transfer on
screen the way that you just said it
would
it totally did so how is it hanging in a
harness was that the first time you've
done that
very uncomfortable trust me we had to
put on like two different suits
underneath
and then like these belts that had to
get straps and then
put on all of the spacesuit uniforms we
were sweating we were uncomfortable but
again
we do anything in order to get that
right take
so that when people go to the theaters
they're like yo this is the most amazing
scene that's what it takes the sacrifice
you did you sacrificed and it totally
paid off because it was my
favorite of the whole movie possibly of
the franchise it was really awesome
um okay so how are you going to top
yourselves what are you going to do next
what are you putting on your bucket list
what do you want what are you putting
out into the ether how are you inspiring
justin this time
so i said that i feel like we need to do
fight scenes somehow underwater
or we need to do fight scenes in air
like
how someone is um like bungee jumping or
skydiving and fighting at the same time
that's the only thing i could possibly
think of like i don't know what else
could be done
time travel jurassic world crossover oh
my god
parallel universe where you're fighting
yourself in an alternate universe i got
loads of ideas for you guys
by the way can you please help explain
how
fast and furious and jurassic world
could make sense of them crossing over
please so the dinosaurs would have to
get teleported to present day right
well or you guys could jump in a time
machine and go faster than you've ever
gone before faster than the speed of
light
hilarious um
talk to me about like the possibility of
a spin-off because i talked to justin
and then a little bit what would you
like to see in terms of the spin-off
would you like to see
you your character and roman like you
know spinning in the
in the outer space for a while you guys
could have a chat show a youtube channel
anything but
what would you like to see for a spin
off i would like to see a spin-off with
all of the women
all of them i'm talking about jordana
michelle
natalie charlize um you know all of the
women in this franchise
i would love to see that i think it
would be badass
well said well said um i want to talk a
little bit about your cast to dinners i
know you had one in london before
and jordana told me that you guys
actually all have to make a toast
i just want to know what the vibe is
like who is that like are you great at
making a toast
how does that go down what are you guys
eating i know you had maybe you stole
natalie's food on set i think you did it
in the past with one of your past cast
mates are you the one stealing all the
food
they're really telling on me oh man i i
eat so much
you know what i will go out and say yes
i stole natalie's food
every time we go to dinners ben makes
everyone
have a speech and make a toast it's the
most incredible thing but we love being
put on the spot
because you know it's just the
appreciation we have for one another and
you get to hear new things each and
every time of why we're so thankful to
to have the best jobs in the world being
a part of the best franchise in the
world
so real quick what was your what did you
put out there this time if you can share
any of it what did you say
what new thing did you share at this
time i was saying that
it's great to be a part of a franchise
movie where people
in a time where streaming is becoming so
popular and people
would prefer to stay at home we are one
of the few franchises where people
want to leave their home still to go get
the theatrical experience
and thank god for it
damn they got a magnet plane about two
major moments in this film
for your character because we see a lot
more of her this time around and in a
very different light than we've seen her
before so first of all
right of passage to finally get behind
the wheel in a fast and furious movie
can you describe that moment
was it like oh my gosh was there any
tips from the cast members not that you
need any about you know
i mean i need the whole point is that
she needs as many as she can get because
she doesn't drive so
it was i i loved that um i finally got
to drive
in the fast and furious movies and i got
to drive in a way that was
non-conventional
to the history of these films like she's
a bad driver and that's just kind of
hilarious
and funny and i also don't drive so
for me it was just like a like poking
fun at that as well and
i got to have fun with it and you know
the kind of clumsy not knowing what what
i was doing
thing came quite naturally so okay okay
so it was
it wasn't hard to because sometimes
maybe it'd be hard to pretend that you
can't drive but
okay the second moment yeah i can drive
but not
i haven't for a long time so it's just
like
my memory is not all there with it um
and the second moment i wanted to talk
about it's the all-female
fight scene and we see a lot more action
from you this time around and we have a
female
writer this time so how did that shape
your character
the dialogue and talk about if you could
just break down that scene for me
when i watched it i was just like blown
away
um by by the kind of just
for like ferocity of our of our amazing
uh female cast i was just like yes it
just
gave me like butterflies in my stomach
it was so good
and um i loved it but i think
the the uh the presence of a female
voice is just really strong
in this film and you know like there are
especially for ramsay like where she's
often having to like take the reigns a
little bit and
um really direct this team and help the
team
um get to the you know next stage of
this mission and so
um you see a lot of the the female
characters having
more responsibility and having um more
stakes
in in in the in the story so it's it's
fantastic
jordana told me she would love to see
some sort of a a
female spin-off everybody's talking
about could there be a crossover with
jurassic world
what would be your ultimate what would
be your ultimate crossover
and what would you see for your
character for a spin-off do you think
that would be
something you would be into
um i would definitely be into a spin-off
with the with the other women of this
franchise
and i think i like my just my
my fantasy is that we somehow bring back
every
iconic female character in the history
of the franchise
and like we're in a cool hideout and
it's like really well decorated because
you know obviously and and then like
everyone's just like
so sick and just being amazing and we
you know
have a great time um but the in terms of
like a crossover i don't know
what's i mean it's hard
it's hard to think of think of it i mean
the jurassic world thing sounds pretty
like crazy so i mean why not
i think well here's what i'll say about
like the last two films before we get to
that moment
um i think vin is kind of teased like we
maybe have to hit all seven continents
in the next film
at least go around the world what is
your dream location to shoot in do you
have
uh if you were going to put in a request
what would be your request for the next
oh like oh gosh the list is really long
um uh i mean i would lo i mean i feel
like they've already been to
um brazil but like i'd love to go
to like japan or you know
somewhere in the east like that would be
really cool or just like selfishly i'd
love to go to like
the the caribbean like to a different
part of the caribbean because i know
they've shot in different places too
because my family are caribbean so i'd
love to go to one of the smaller islands
there
or i don't know like um somewhere
like i mean they've shot in iceland so i
don't know
like what haven't they done right yeah
australia would be good as well
perfect choice i was so hot that's my
bucket list choice for you guys i know
you said in an interview before
that you want john cena to be your life
coach that you're so into the wwe you're
a wrestling fan
i talked to him about it yesterday i
asked him if he knew that about you he
said he didn't know
and i asked him for life advice but why
do you want john cena to be your life
coach
have you seen his twitter he's so wise
he's so he just says the like most
amazing like
real like life lessons and i was like
this guy is so
switched on and like he just really gets
it and i thought
john cena could be a great life coach
because he seems to have
so he's so like sensitive to
you know those big life lessons that we
can all learn from and he tweets these
amazing things and i'm like
yeah he's smart like i i would happily
let him
give me advice as a life coach
so first of all we see your character as
well
as a younger dom um in this film
and the guys that played those
characters an amazing job of sort of
picking up your nuances and it made me
think back to like what was john cena
like as a teenager
if your part of your life was a movie
scene that we flash back to
was this you know do you think that
everything that's happening now was sort
of in the stars
or was there a metamorphosis what was
your high school like
man i don't know how uh how much of
that would would have been determined
then i know that i was
structurally rebellious is the best way
i can say that
uh continuously challenging authority
and norms
i think in the way that an adolescent
probably does
but also uh really
grateful for the structure i had i lived
in boarding school um
i was a two-sport athlete dedicated to
physical fitness
and you know just
all that stuff but at the same time i
regularly challenged authority and
wow faced its wrath many times
structurally rebellious i think is a
good way
i think that should be a new phrase
structurally rebellious well i know
natalie said that she wants you to be
her life coach
i don't know if she told you that but
has she told you that and if that is the
case and you are a life coach for
everybody out there what would be your
number one piece of
advice um
i would say uh start every day grateful
and end every day fulfilled
wow so did she tell you this by the way
did you have you heard this before
really no that's news to me i'm very
flattered
um i want to talk a little bit about
fast and furious
is what they're doing with fast nine i
think is so much
fan service they're giving the fans what
they've been wanting they always want
more family
they gave they gave us more family with
your character
you know they're bringing han back outer
space the whole thing
so we're never satisfied though as fans
we're always thinking ahead so i'm
thinking
ahead to where we can see possibly your
character go
and if we're talking about giving the
fans what they want would you ever see a
match up
with your character in hobbs jacob and
hobbes
i mean you've met up in the ring what do
you think that would be like to meet up
in an acting scene um
i i don't know uh i i
i think it would be very entertaining i
i i'm
i'm glad that that's kind of the the
the word amongst the fans because the
fans truly control
the success of the film so if if people
want to see more
that may mean that i get to be another
in in another one of these things
um and i really had a lot of fun but i
think it speaks volumes to the
the monster star power that the cast of
fast and furious is to say that like
hey we can now do these crazy mythical
matchups and see if they happen
i think just even having that
conversation is an important testament
to the franchise and
and the people associated with the
franchise and um
man that that just it we'll see that all
seems so surreal but i i
you never know i guess okay so if you're
going toe-to-toe
the rock or there's a rumors of a
crossover with
um jurassic world the rock or a raptor
what do you think would be your tougher
opponent to go up against in a scene
ooh uh that's like a tale of the tape
uh i i uh dwayne is is such a
unique and successful and unreal
individual i think
he certainly he trumps anything
prehistoric
oh really i i honestly think that that
i think the the raptor would be uh
entertaining for a split second
i i think um the possible storyline
capabilities of
the combination you mentioned i think
would be much more entertaining well i
think
everybody would love to see that um
because you guys have such a history in
the ring it'd be really cool because i
know he also gave you acting advice
about sort of being yourself
not only that that's life advice it gave
me a really good life advice when i was
uh
just really concerned about behaving a
certain way
it was in 2012 and he was like hey man
just be yourself they
called you there for a reason he was
almost upset that i didn't know that
just be yourself they called you there
for a reason
and that really that's that's stuck
because
i was comfortable being myself yeah and
uh
one last question i know that you said
um
acting in a movie is and for the fans in
this franchise it's almost like being in
the ring where you earn it you earn that
audience's respect
um step by step piece by piece was there
a moment filming this
where you thought to yourself okay i
think i've earned it
i mean joining this franchise is such a
huge thing so what was that moment for
you where you really hooked it and felt
that
uh so i felt a sense of family very
early
on and also um from from both having to
earn it like
they were very standoffish in
questioning my intentions but when they
saw that my intentions were true they
welcomed me into the family
i i look at life in a sense of if you
think you have earned it
then you you have a lot to learn
i don't think i've reached the point
where i've ever
earned it i think is always something to
be earned and i think the fast family
operates in that capacity
they have eight movies and six plus
billion to rest their hat
on but they do not do that they forge
forward and they continue to try to top
themselves
in cinematography in plausible practical
practical action in cast acquisition in
narrative
in giving the fans what they want in
winking to the camera on occasion like
they lean into
everything when essentially they could
say like we've earned it
we don't have to they just refuse so i
can't
fall in line the rest of my laurels when
the people around me don't
you know i just i don't look at it that
way hey guys
surprise nice clubhouse hi
i know when you got to your trailer on
set for fast nine
you were actually in helen mirren's
trailer
her trailer her tea was there and her
sides her script
did drink her tea did you sneak a peek
at her script
i i drank her tea because she drinks png
tea
to this day i still drink png tea
because she drinks it
right i i swear because yeah i was like
if she drinks if it's good enough for
helen mirren it's good enough for me
because i
you know i don't know british tea so i
was like which one do i buy you know
like and i was like a png it's easy to
remember
if she drinks it if if the dame drinks
it i'm going to drink it
did you read the script did you peek at
her part yeah
yes because i wanted to see how what her
process was
you know does she highlight everything
well she doesn't right
you know what is an academy award winner
yeah there were a lot of notes yeah
little little markings here and there
yeah oh the t no i'm i'm kidding i'll
move on but that's
that is very very cool um i am a huge
han stan
i love tokyo drift so do so many people
there's something about his your
presence on screen
that i use the word profound i find his
presence profound and when i
i when i knew you were coming back and i
saw that first moment i'm like please
don't let me down please let it be
amazing and it was
it was profound did it feel that way for
you profound i
i wouldn't use the word profound i would
just say
you know it was i was just nervous
nervous and a lot of
a lot of anxiety and anxious and feeling
a little
insecure am i gonna fit in again you
know um
so yeah i don't i don't see myself as
profound or anything so you know i don't
see it at that point it's just like
i hope i can do it justice i hope i can
actually i hope they don't find out that
i don't know what i'm doing is really
all that's going on in my head
you know um but for the tokyo drifters
i would say oh boy are they in for a
surprise you know
this is yeah this is i think they're
going to be happy you know
i think i'd be really happy i think they
are too it is
uh it's i think you called it like a
feast or a buffet or something for
uh the entire film really for everybody
i find your performance profound but i i
appreciate the humility
in your answer and the realness in your
answer and you use the word justice and
it really was
you know justice for han and the hashtag
that brought this character back
i want to bring up a new hashtag that i
want to start trending
and that is spin-off for han
this is what i want to see next i've
heard you say that you'd be in for it
um where would you like to see han go do
you sort of want
to have answers for where he's been and
go in that direction would you like to
move forward
and is there is the shaw showdown just
the inevitable because
he said jason has said he would love it
that he feels like it's the inevitable
yeah um i would love to work with jason
again you know i'm a fan anyway
so um uh you know to to be able to
uh share screen time with them and have
a story line
together that would be great um and yeah
i mean
i think anything is possible with like
you know what can happen
in the fast universe and you know where
i would love
um you know a spin-off for han to go to
it's like we're kind of
you know the um the comic book heroes
kind of went
to the dark side like wolverine and
deadpool i think
there's room to kind of go rated r
version of uh you know fast and furious
so
when hark when han went dark when he
what happens to a person when you lose
the love of your life you know you're
not gonna all of a sudden wake up and go
i'm listening to tony robbins and i'm
gonna start the day with sunshine you
know there's going to be a dark period
right
dark period of morning and i think i
would i would love to explore that part
of like
you know how did he come out of that you
know what brought him out of that dark
you know that dark place but listen
never say never that giselle can't come
back because you're the coolest of cool
couples of all time
listen people have called you the yoda
of this franchise
speaking of yoda yeah yeah i know you're
working on the obi-wan series
if if the fast series is all about
family how would you describe working on
a star wars series
huh oh that's a great question
well uh fast oh the star wars series i
would say
how would you i guess i would use the
word
legacy legacy legacy
in the most humble way is that the
feeling that i get
on set is oh aside from the characters
is that
every single crew member you look in
their eyes
and it's like a kid going i grew up
you know watching star wars like this is
my dream to be here like
to see one of the you know star wars
character or darth vader character
you know uh one of the jedi's walking
around like no matter how old they are
you know it's like this if the 80 year
old like guys that do my you know
special effect
my you know my my my makeup and stuff
and
people who do the costumes to all the
set designers there's this feeling of
legacy and it's like everyone talks
about history and
you know why they you know they feel so
blessed
to be here right and so there's this
history
there's this kind of shared spirit and
this passion of
why we wanted to come into hollywood and
you know the connected tissue is all
these star wars characters you know like
i used to dress up you know these kmart
like hollywood
halloween costumes like i had a darth
vader one and it looks like a skywalker
one
it was all put together with like duct
tape after a while and the fact that i'm
you know actually on set and they're
putting like a star wars
costume on me come on it's like
like pinch yourself right so because
this character han was spawned out of
better luck tomorrow
and it was kind of a you know it was a
version of the character carried on is
there another franchise or movie that
you could see
han jumping into that just dream kind of
throwing it out there
that you think would be a cool uh
extension of han
yeah i think he could go he could be a
character in one of the ocean movies
don't you think like ocean
14 or 15 right right he shows up to be
the driver for one of the heists right
and but right right oh he's just
he delivers some snacks to the guys i
don't know you know
so that would be cool huh there's
nothing more powerful than the lover
family
but you turn that into anger there's
nothing more dangerous
i wanted to ask you you know this is
probably one of the first if not the
first movie people will see back in
theaters
after not going to the theater for a
long time it was actually my first
uh what is going to the movies and the
cinematic experience and
going to the cinema meant to you in your
life oh well
you know that's an interesting question
because obviously historically
um you know the going to the cinema was
your opportunity to get out of the house
wasn't it when you were sort of
14 15 16 years old so you know and you
could only ever do it at the weekend
you know friday night or saturday night
so it was always a very very sort of
special occasion
um in fact i didn't go to the cinema
much when i was young because
partly for financial reasons we
literally couldn't afford to go to the
cinema
um but also you know i i think it was
sort of complicated getting to the
cinema
in the small town that i grew up in um
but subsequently um i became an
usherette
actually in a in um i i was an usher at
in the days when they used to have
usherettes
showing you to your seat in a sort of
art house cinema and i had a little
torch
and a black uniform and i would show
people to their seats
but um and this was while i was in
college it was my sort of
you know saturday job um and of course i
saw all these great movies because it
was an art house uh
cinema so i saw one great great movie
after another
and and that really introduced me to the
unbelievable sort of
magic of of movies and i think the whole
idea
of sitting in a darkened room with a lot
of other people
um hopefully a lot of other people um
that
where you're communally engaging in in
an experience
there's it's very fundamental and human
and
and
very a very wonderful experience even
more so when you have a film
like fast and furious which has to be a
communal
exciting experience where you can yell
you can
shout you can laugh you can you know you
can experience it together you're
allowed to be vocal
you know you don't you don't watch fast
and furious in hushed sort of silence do
you
no not how i watched it and you have to
watch how you're driving on the way home
and i wanted to ask you
you are finally driving in this i know
at last i'm behind the wheel with a
with a gear shift of course i can drive
a gear shift
well i know you've been on top gear i
know some of your pass rolls even queen
and elizabeth
ii you did some driving in that land
right i did in the land rover
but was there anything was not that you
need any help but did you get any tips
from vin or anybody about
driving in a fast movie or did you give
them any tips or anything to add to your
repertoire
well i think you know the these guys you
know you you do two kinds of driving in
in fast and furious you do the real
driving on the street but you also do
the driving in
in an articulated you know car on the
set
so um that was a very you had to
remember
exactly where the turns were and things
like that
um which incidentally was the other
difficulty on
on the um uh the car show that i did
top gear it was remembering the turns
this was always the hardest thing
because you're you're driving
so fast uh that you have to oh no you go
left here
um no i mean
um these guys obviously are incredibly
experienced but i'm a pretty experienced
driver actually as well and
and i did grow up dr uh driving a gear
shift so i know that very well and i
i do know how to double de-clutch that
that just was the coolest thing i think
you could have ever said i know how to
find
a clutch that's driver real quick
queenie queen elizabeth ii in the queen
or jane tennyson and prime sun's
suspect who's the best driver oh
oh queenie definitely queenie
oh yes absolutely i know that you put
out in the universe
several years ago i want to be in a fast
movie you spoke about it you made it
happen you manifested it then you said
i want to drive in this movie and it
happens yes
let's go to fast10 what's number one on
your request list
oh i think i think a good fight sequence
would be great
you know a really good fight sequence
would be excellent
so driving and fighting yeah well let's
accelerate it a little bit more
would you ever see queenie in a hobbs
and shaw spin-off
type hobsons shot type spin-off movie
would you like queenie to have her own
film oh i see you know she's an
interesting character
you know this sort of east end woman
comes from you know the the underworld
if you like of the east end
world a world i know fairly well my
my uncle actually was a gangster in in
the east end
sort of pre-war and and just post-war
so it is a world i know a little bit um
uh so and and there are some very fierce
and strong women in that world and
um yeah it would be it would be great
uh one thing i love about it i mean and
it should of course be called queenie
so then i would have been in a film
called the queen and then also in a film
called queenie
it knows what it goes without saying and
incidentally she's named after my aunt
my aunt was actually called queenie
auntie queenie it's an old east end
name i thought that it was after your
character obviously no no not at all no
i was named after my east end
born aunt so i wanted to ask you
queenie one of the things i think i love
about her she always makes an entrance
you don't know if she's going to show up
in prison garbs in jewels
he's never phased like helen mirren what
is
the greatest entrance or the biggest
entrance you think you've ever made in
your life
i've made a few embarrassing entrances i
have to say you know usually to do with
falling downstairs
not necessarily you know drunk
[Laughter]
often more to do with an entanglement of
high heels and
long skirts you know which is always a
very very um
difficult thing uh
i was people thought i'd fallen down on
the
on the wonderful stairs going up to the
entrance in can you know when you go to
the cannes film festival there's this
amazing staircase
and i very gracefully walked up the
stairs in my beautiful gown and then i
noticed when i got to the top of the
stairs
that the guy the head of the festival
greets you i noticed his shoelaces were
undone
so i very elegantly and gracefully sank
to my feet
in front of him and tied up his
shoelaces
for him which you know it was kind of
funny thing too
i would think but then in all the
newspapers it said that i fell down
you know at the top of the stairs um
so i've taken quite a few public tumbles
whether they were real
tumbles or not i know you've said in the
past that you felt like the bond
franchise
should have had a female villain yes you
were going to play i think for the first
time a villainess in this movie so
i know you haven't really started yet
but what do you hope to bring in terms
of a
female villainess like we've never seen
before oh
it's it's very hard to do something that
you've never seen before
um but you know this is this character
is is ambivalent actually you never
quite know
on whose side she's on um
and also she's a goddess so really once
you're a goddess you can go in any
direction you like
can't you um so uh you know i don't know
i i'll just have to let it happen when
it happens
you know but a goddess like quality i
[Music]
hope
so justin first i wanted to ask you i
know you have been influenced by the
golden girls in your life
how did it influence fast nine and who
is blanche which character is blanche
well you know i i think growing up i was
the kid that hung out stayed home on
saturday nights
and uh one night they had this uh
hurricane
saturday night and it was golden girl
empty nest and it was like it was the
starch
and it all happened i was like oh these
shows are all in the same universe so
um it continues to inspire me
in that a lot of our characters are are
from
you know everywhere but the fact that
you know we can all exist in the same
world
uh that's the spirit of golden girls yes
and you need to have a hurricane now
this is my
this is what i'm taking away from it um
at what point i i heard you say that you
and vin looked at each other and you
said
fast nine this is the one this is where
we're going to outer space was it when
you locked eyes with each other what was
that moment that you had that divine
understanding between the two of you why
was this the one because you could have
waited
until the final film yeah it's
interesting because we've always kind of
talked about
all these crazy ideas you know and as i
was working on it
um there was uh we were working on roman
and tej
and roman's having a little bit of an
existential crisis
and i was sitting there going wow where
is this going to lead and then it
somehow just kind of
went to space and i thought am i crazy
so i called i called vin and i said hey
man i got to come over
i went to his house i remember it was
around christmas because the trees were
up and everything
and then we looked at each other i
talked to him and we looked at each
other and we're like
yeah let's do it you just knew yeah this
is the one and that's where
where you saw the pictures of you know
everybody on the wall bin has like a
wall of
everybody and oh and strings he has
strings
to everything yeah yeah it looks like a
look like a serial killer
if you look at my note cards it's kind
of the same so i kind of understand
um obviously you were the only director
to bring back han
and that's such a huge moment for fans i
know was it 100 driven by fans was
that always kind of something in the
back of your mind or did they bring that
to your attention and then
what do you think fans are going to take
away from it because it's
i don't want to give anything away but
it's a moment yeah
it's a hundred percent because of the
fans um
and when i was away i didn't watch the
the films and then i started hearing
this thing about justice for han and i
thought
is it that fast and furious han it's my
heart
you know and yeah so i
and i looked into it and um and i
i found out what happened and i thought
i was equally baffled you know
and and uh and maybe a little upset
um but then so when i came back i felt
like okay well we got to correct this
and i think what what's great about fast
nine is that it's a promise
to find justice for han so it you know
the the the fact that he's able to
rejoin us
it has special meaning to me and i know
to the fans
but it's a promise that the true justice
is going to be
yeah a longer road which means a lot
more han
well speaking of the longer road you
kind of are thinking of
or at least saying that you're going to
wrap things up with the next film
and i know you've said that uh directing
is almost like a salad bar you can go in
a lot of different directions a lot of
different combinations do you have it in
your mind do you invent sort of have
that
end game in mind or is it still fluid it
it actually
we pretty much have it kind of set uh
it's it's conversation that that that we
had
you know i think we started probably
like 2010
you know and and even paul paul was part
of that conversation
you know and i've always thought it was
just an exercise of
what if and and and the fact that we're
here
it just felt like wow you know we we've
always talked about earning our new
chapters and now
talking about final chapter there was
something that
that felt very gratifying in that that
we've earned so i think
we've been kind of crafting this for a
while so i think in the general term
we kind of know where it's going to go
but the the the roads are gonna
that's gonna get there that's still
being built until the fans tell you
no no we're not done we need we need
toretto in a t-rex well
you know it's interesting because uh
when i started
there you know there wasn't a lot of
people as part of a community
you know and and it just kept growing so
i think it's really respect
uh uh respecting kind of not only us the
cast
the crew but it's it's it took everybody
to build
this franchise and and we definitely
respect that and love that and and love
the passion so
um we never want to we always want to
respect it so
um but but but yeah it's always open
oh hell now
[Applause]